日本には宗教を信じる人はたくさんいるが進行しのある人はほとんどいない
石原さとみさんより蒼井そらさんのほうが演技が上手い
東京の一番良い観光地は横浜でやる最も素晴らしいアイドルグループは akb 0だ
アニメは誤りじゃなかった金曜日の夜の渋谷はもう少し込んだ
写してもおかしくないパロウィンの渋谷を見たことある近藤麻理恵さんはもうちょっと
物を捨てるはずだ
前走は見たことあるスノー選手はみんなもっと太ってもいいような気がするアメリカ人
見たことある
misia より初音ミクの方が疑うない新幹線覚えといに訳すのは不自然だ
なんとかなんとか靖国神社史上最高
の日本ゲームソフトは室井の封印だ佐々木希さんより宇佐美里香さんの方が断然美しい
喧嘩売ってんじゃねーぞ
高校デビューより好きあのとろーりチーズ牛丼の方がおいしい
コナンはハインリヒ文芸を見習うべきだ日本一性格のいいユーチューバーは絆愛ちゃん
1998年のこちらは市場
委員こちらな新しいスマッシュブラザーズはブラザーズが足りない魚天国よりお肉食べ
音の歌のほうがいい
毎食お米を食べる必要がないすでに3したものに印鑑をつける必要がない鼻水が出ても
病院に行かなくても大丈夫だ
日本一おいしい緑茶は僕のアパートの伸びにある自販機から出てくるもの
だ宇多田ヒカルのアルバムの中で一番洗練されているのは exodus たーーー
書くことに関しては感じよりカタカナの方が難しい
初代のポケモンの中で一番かっこいいのはラットトラップだ
サラリーマンより ol の方が仕事に線を出している外国人の大多数は日本人より
心配事が少ないん
ni